three are not to be that is the question
whether tis nobler in the mind to suffer
the slings and I was a very just
fortunate console to see him troubles
and by opposing end them to die to sleep
to sleep perchance to dream mother you
get the idea Michael machine man he
presenting a genuine original closely
collectible most micromachines
a lot of people know me as the micro
machine man or the FedEx guy or a
terrible tester virgin from Saved by the
Bell or just that guy who talks fast in
fact I was in the Guinness Book is the
world's fastest talker and so for the
last 40 years have you needed a fast
talker I was your go-to guy is that okay
did you get everything you need I mean I
can repeat it again if you want you sure
you don't want 12 years old I wanted to
get into the Guinness Book of World
Records so I figured the only thing I
could really do since I wasn't gonna eat
a car or swallow lead pipe was to lock
myself in a room and teach myself a
stocking and I did that with the hamlet
soliloquy years later I'm at this party
fancy California Beverly Hills party and
a friend of mine is trying to pick up
this valley girl he's from New York and
talking pretty quickly and she looks at
him and says Nick oh my gosh are you
like the world's fastest talker and he
says no as a matter of fact this person
is they called me over and I did one of
my little party routines they could come
up to pick a cup up to be my big
difficult to pick up a club and a guy
walked over he says that's incredible
I'm a producer and I'm gonna put you on
a show I went on the show and I did the
fast-talking thinking that would be it
and all of a sudden the phone starts
ringing and I'm booked all over the
place and I managed to make a living out
of it
I can speak as fast as eleven words a
second now I never do 11 words a second
for TV well let me do Peter Piper at 11
words a second pick up a cup up to pick
up up up to be back with you about
difficult to pick up a key to perfect
and you kind of hear me going pop pop
pop but that's really are you kind of
getting but when you do TV there's
visual reinforcement people see you and
do whatever so I do about seven to eight
words a second that would sound
something like
the publishers deed to Peter Piper pick
it Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled
swiss to pick up pick up speed now on
radio I have to do it even a little
slower because you have no visual
reinforcement you're not seeing me so
then I do about five to six words a
second so it sounds something like and
that's kind of the secret to my success
because if you can't understand what I'm
saying they're not gonna pay me the big
bucks
now the very first commercial I did was
the Federal Express commercial it is to
this day the most award-winning
commercial in the history of advertising
the final scene I'm sitting behind a
desk and I'm going you know Dave what's
the deal with the deal are we dealing
David to deal with Donovan to deal with
dog so I did the thing like 29 times
without making a mistake and the
director said to me what do you like a
machine you never make a mistake I said
you want a mistake I'll give you a
mistake the next time so I said David's
a dork with dick Donald Duck and that's
the take II ended up putting in the
commercial it's a new one the first time
I saw it I called this John it's our
little secret
although I'm known as the world's
fastest talker I do not choose to live
by entire life in the fast lane
sometimes I just like to take it all a
little slower but sometimes it's really
really good to be fast
you
[Music]
you